the opening scene features an 8-year-old
little girl named Rose Daniels who is
seen talking to some unseen entity in
the thicket in the back of her house she
is sad because her loving elder brother
is about to leave for his university
education Rose lives with her father
Nate Daniels her mother Mary Daniels and
her brother Eric Daniels it appears that
the Daniels have a very good bond with
their Nextdoor Neighbors The Waters they
often gather at one another's place to
have their meals and dinners together
Dan Waters and Nate are not just
neighbors but childhood buddies and his
daughter Jessica loves Rose as her own
little sister however it is clear that
Jessica and Eric do not get along well
with each other probably because of some
upsetting history and perhaps because of
Cooties one day the Daniels arrange a
little farewell party for Eric and
invite their neighbors as well as some
of Eric's friends Nate announces that
his son is going to attend his dream
college umw with a distinguished
academic and athletic scholarship
everyone is excited about his new
adventure but poor Rose feels quite the
opposite she does not want to be apart
from her brother as a result she
abruptly leaves the lunch table and
walks into the woods Eric follows and
discovers her next to a trunk where he
had written roses and his initials he
reassures her that everything will be
fine because her big brother will never
leave her side no matter where he goes
unless he goes to jail later that
evening Nate and Mary leave for some
work while Eric also prepares for his
rugby practice as a result Jessica
decides to stay with rose until her
parents return before Eric departs he
has a private moment with Jessica it is
at this moment we learn that he likes
her he has even proposed to her in the
past but she turned him down he asks if
she has changed her heart to which she
replies in the negative this clearly
makes him upset but despite this he
opposes when his friends make
disparaging remarks about Jessica as
night falls Jessica reads Rose a bedtime
story and Tucks her in before falling
asleep the little girl confides in her
about her friend in the woods Jessica is
initially perplexed but she doesn't want
to offend her so she claims that she
believes in her unlike Eric who thinks
it's nothing more than her imagination
later the parents return home and
discover that Rose is missing Mary asks
the sleeping Eric but he also has no
idea about her whereabouts in a state of
panic she goes to the wat's place and
demands her daughter's whereabouts
because it was Jessica who was with her
most recently as all of this is
happening Eric does not seem to be
concerned at all indicating that
something is wrong with them unable to
locate the girl anywhere the parents
file a missing person's report
thankfully the police managed to find
Rose within a few hours in the woods
which should have been obvious this news
finally enables the parents to breathe a
sigh of relief while Eric remains
visibly discontent as they return home
with rose Eric senses something a miss
in his sister's Behavior because she
can't even find her own room she wanders
around the house for a while appearing
as if she is there for the first time
the following morning Mary prepares
Rose's favorite breakfast but the little
girl refuses to eat it she also has
developed an interest in Wildlife TV
shows that depict animals feeding on the
Flesh of others I just love it when they
kill later Mary asks her if she wants to
play with her best friend Anna tomorrow
but much to her astonishment Rose
doesn't even recognize I her best friend
Mary starts to get worried upon
witnessing her strange Behavior she
confides it in her husband and suggests
that they take her for therapy but Nate
dismisses her concern telling her not to
overthink it one night Eric Peaks into
Rose's room and finds her standing in
front of the mirror with unsettling
Expressions sensing someone watching her
Rose turns around revealing her entirely
black eyes Eric freaks out and hastily
shuts the door hearing this sound the
parents Rush towards Rose's room but
find her normal in bed this incident
raises a strong suspicion in Eric's mind
and he thinks that something evil has
possessed her body the next day he
Witnesses another unusual sight Rose
consuming worms from the garden
delicious and nutritious on another
night Eric Ventures to the woods with a
flashlight in search of the answers to
the ongoing unusual events while walking
he senses the presence of something and
is suddenly startled by a movement he
turns around to check only to see
Jessica staring from her window in a
creepy way unable to stay there any
longer Eric quickly returns home in the
morning he prepares some normal bacon
for rose for breakfast but the girl
doesn't want to eat it that's not worms
when he insists she consumes it but soon
goes outside to throw up Eric observes
this from the window but decides not to
confront her later at night he attends a
party where he enjoys some drinks with
his friends there he also spots a hot
girl girl and starts dancing with her a
few moments later he sees Jessica and an
injured rose on the dark and chaotic
Dance Floor she's about to do the worm a
chill runs down Eric's spine prompting
him to leave the party abruptly
following this he heads home driving
through the dark and empty road during
this he notices Rose in the back seat
which scares his heart out this causes
him to crash his car into the sideline
concrete he hastily gets out of his car
and checks the back seat initially he
finds no one inside but he is soon
startled by a strange creature that runs
towards the woods not long after a
police patrol car arrives at the scene
and the officer detains Eric for drunk
driving and speeding afterwards Nate
comes to the police station and bails
his son out from custody back home Mary
is very upset by his irresponsible
Behavior unaware of what's actually
going on with him on the other hand
Jessica despite maintaining a positive
relationship with Eric's family tries to
distance herself from them one evening
she and her father stopped by a cafe
where they unintentionally bump into
Eric and his father Nate invites them to
join them for the dinner to which Dan
agrees during this Jessica feels very
uneasy but she tries to appear normal
however she can't restrain herself for
much longer and as a result she walks
away from the place her father follows
her while Nate and Eric remain confused
as the days pass by Jessica resorts to
shutting herself in her room and
avoiding everyone on a particular night
Eric looks through his binoculars at
Jessica's room like a proper creepy s
boy and discovers that she is preparing
to injure herself panicked he rushes to
her place and wakes her parents up when
they arrive at her room they are shocked
to see her in such a miserable State as
a result Jessica is rushed to the
hospital Dan is baffled as to why his
cheery daughter made such a drastic move
while waiting for her to regain her
Consciousness Dan talks to Eric and asks
if he knows about anything that is
bothering ing Jessica Eric responds in
the negative and tells him that they are
not as close as they used to be when Dan
asks for the reason Eric opts not to
disclose about their relationship and
claims that their separate peer groups
LED them to be a part Upon returning
back home he locks himself inside the
bathroom and stands in front of the
mirror he closes his eyes as several
visions of Jessica and Rose deeply
unsettle him later he goes to his room
and looks at a photo album reminiscing
some good memories from the past a short
while later Mary walks into his room to
inform him that she and his father will
be away for work the next day she asks
if he can look after Rose to which he
says yes the following morning as soon
as the parents leave Eric confronts Rose
and asks who she is and what she wants
from him he also claims that he is well
aware she is not his sister but rather a
malevolent supernal being Rose's eyes
then turned black I'm the worm queen as
she responds that she wants nothing
however she knows that he wants to kill
her this scares Eric so he quickly grabs
a kitchen knife just then the disguised
Rose says that they now have company
Eric turns around to look through the
window and finds Jessica standing
outside his house she is staring at him
as if she has a lot of hatred for him
following this Eric rushes to her and
yells at her asking why she is troubling
him so much in a fit of rage he even
pushes Rose to the ground before or
walking inside his home later Eric goes
to the shower where he screams his anger
out after a while he decides to kill the
disguised Rose and end all of this once
and for all he then grabs a knife and
breaks into a room he does not find the
girl there but instead notices several
sketches that depict a strange creature
and a particular place in the woods Eric
seems to know that spot so he heads
towards it carrying a spade with him
once there he starts digging the ground
and soon reveals Rose's hand here it is
disclosed that Eric was the one who
murdered Rose and hid her body in the
woods right then the possessed Rose
shows up at the scene and tells him that
she was there and saw everything the
mysterious entity then reveals its true
form which is like a dangerous Beast
despite being in shock Eric does not
flee the scene because he is already
tired of running away from the truth he
then begs for death so that he can get
freedom from all of this mental trauma
however the creature wants to avenge
Rose's death in some other way the
entity inflicts its sharp nails into
Eric's mind forcing him to relive
memories which he is desperately trying
to forget the scene then cuts to a
flashback and we are shown the same
night when Eric's parents were away for
work during that time Rose woke up to
the screaming voice of Jessica upon
heading downstairs she witnessed Eric
forcing himself on her she shouted at
her brother to stop which caused Eric to
freeze for a while while this
distraction allowed Jessica to free
herself and run back to her place after
that Eric tried to manipulate Rose to
keep her mouth shut but the girl refused
to be persuaded and ran away into the
woods a Chase ensued during which Rose's
foot slipped and she ended up banging
her head on a hard surface resulting in
her bleeding heavily the poor girl
pleaded with her brother for help but
Eric left her to die just to keep his
mistake hidden he then buried her there
and returned back home unaware of the
fact that Rose's invisible friend
witnessed everything this explains why
Eric behaved unusually earlier when Rose
returned home we also learned that
Jessica had been behaving in such a way
because she couldn't Express her
humiliation to anyone as she didn't want
to strain the relationship between the
two families back in the present the
creature opts not to Grant Eric an easy
death but rather to torment him with
memories and burn him with regrets now
that it has disclosed everything to
Jessica she calls the police to have him
arrested in the final scene we see
Jessica thrashing Eric with a spade as
the police arrive to take him into
custody subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching